[Music]
[Music]
Carrie Underwood got a standing ovation
of her cried pretty performance and a
quick kiss from hubby Mike Fisher after
winning female video over the year was a
huge night for Carrie Underwood at the
CMT's she now solidified her record when
she has 18 CMT Awards Carrie Underwood
this was Carrie's second award show
appearances the accident that left her
with nearly 50 stitches in her face
thank you God for you guys but it was
Blake Shelton who took home the top
prize of the night Blake Shelton oh man
the dog I can't believe I've been doing
this for 18 years
[Music]
Blake who also performed arrived solo
leaving everybody asking where was Gwen
well each he has learned Gwen had to
miss the show because she is deep in
rehearsals for her Vegas residency which
opens in 20 days still she tweeted Blake
support and they spent the weekend
together at a wedding and on a boat with
her boys and fellow boys coach Kelly
Clarkson hit the stage adding a gospel
touch to a rock classic
Kelly showed off her slim down in a
body-hugging short black dress the
singer has reportedly lost 40 pounds I
thought Sam I love it I love on carries
don't blink
I love all your stuff you guys send me
and Carrie under it thank you as well
because I've lost weight since you sent
this so it's all too big for you which
make me feel rapid bed
[Music]
meanwhile Luke Bryan shut it down in the
middle of the town he calls home you're
getting me in all kind of trouble I'm
gonna wake up in the morning I'm like
hey man I shouldn't have said that
that's because you said you wanted to
marry go into Blake left as Elvis that's
what he said last time
I'll go get a rhinestone jumpsuit and
marry Blake and Glen and Blake has a
rebuttal it's not even a legitimate
country artist and then there's another
rebuttal
gonna talk about the guys name that
rhymes with Lake he always chains me
Little Big Town both opened the show
with their new single and did a
fantastic job playing host for the night
and Sugarland unleashed this 30-second
teaser for their upcoming video with
Taylor Swift faith tailor the treatment
for its redheaded tailor they told me
Taylor also co-wrote the song and
channels our inner Christina Hendricks
from Mad Men while playing the other
woman to the Backstreet the Backstreet
Boys have come their first CMT Music
Award for their collaboration with
Florida Georgia line now that this club
is so great you hang out I'm gonna
actually go do some yoga with them in a
couple days you're not really
[Music]